foreign
[Music]
has invited more derision than Sympathy
for the victims a couple that ridiculed
the idea that the world is a big scary
place was murdered by the Islamic State
Isis while they were biking through
Tajikistan but those who were mocking
jay Austin and Lauren gagan for their
naivete are being too harsh the
responsibility for their deaths lies not
just with Isis or with the starry-eyed
couple but also with the leftist world
in which they moved and lived the left's
leaders constructed a fantasy world
because leftist ideas are dead on the
drawing board without one
in their fantasy world Islam is peace
borders and nation states are unwelcome
relics of a bygone age because people
are good everywhere with the exception
of course of Donald Trump and the far
right
Austin an employee of the Department of
Housing and Urban Development and gagan
who worked at Georgetown University
decided two years ago to leave their
jobs and go on a bike ride around the
world they kept a Blog about their
Journey on which Austin wrote this last
April
you watch the news and you read the
papers and you're led to believe that
the world is a big scary place people
The Narrative goes are not to be trusted
people are bad people are evil people
are ax murderers and monsters and worse
I don't buy it evil is a make-believe
concept we've invented to deal with the
complexities of fellow humans holding
values and beliefs and perspectives
different from our own it's easier to
dismiss an opinion as abhorrent than
strive to understand it Badness exists
sure but even that's quite rare by and
large humans are kind self-interested
sometimes myopic sometimes but kind
generous and wonderful and kind no
greater Revelation has come from our
journey than this
yes Austin and gagan were unwise to
carry this polyanish philosophy into
Muslim Central Asia but they didn't
originate it in this sad episode Isis is
not the only one with blood on their
hands where did Austin get the idea that
evil is a make-believe concept perhaps
in today's universities which are
saturated with moral relativism
contemptuous of absolutes and
dogmatically convinced that there is no
dispute between people that can't be
settled by mutually respectful dialogue
this perspective dominates contemporary
culture and is taken for granted even at
the highest levels when Barack Obama and
John Kerry entered into negotiations
with the Islamic Republic of Iran they
were working upon the assumption that it
was wrong to think that people are not
to be trusted and that people are evil
Obama and Kerry were essentially
embracing the idea that evil is a
make-believe concept that the mullahs
were perhaps self-interested sometimes
myopic sometimes but ultimately
good-hearted
the leftist Intelligentsia was and still
is unanimous in applauding that
initiative
likewise it is a matter of dogmatic
certainty for the left that Islam is a
religion of peace and that only racist
bigoted islamophobes think otherwise why
should Austin and gagan have had any
reason to be concerned about bicycle
riding through the Muslim majority
countries of Central Asia after all
those who don't believe that evil is a
make-believe concept are subject to
Furious and concerted demonization the
Southern Poverty Law Center and the
establishment media that treats the splc
as if it were a reliable source sees
only one group of genuinely evil people
in the world those who recognize that
there are evil forces in the world that
are set against the United States and
who want to protect Americans against
Islamic jihadists criminal migrants and
more they're the only evil ones Austin
and gagan no doubt had nothing but
contempt for such intolerance and Hate
manifested by foes of jihad Terror and
unrestricted illegal immigration
the left forces people to believe these
fantasies lest they be charged with
hatred and bigotry the people who filled
Austin and gagan's heads with this
nonsense bullied them towards their
deaths
the problem with these fantasies is that
reality keeps breaking through Jay
Austin and Lauren gagan discovered too
late that some people really are evil
Will the west rid itself of these
leftist fantasies that led to their
deaths before many more end up dead from
embracing them
I'm Robert Spencer a showman fellow for
the David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the center for
security policy
[Music]